quelques instants nous allons faire de
la randonnée aquatique dans le parc
national de port cros avec olivier
théron et didier beaumont ça fait
presque une heure depuis l'embarcadère
au port d'hyères kenzo attend de voir la
silhouette de port-cros port cros dans
une méditerranée qui est touriste
s'accapare c'est l'île oubliée préservé
par son statut de parc national c'est un
peu un voyage dans le temps que
d'accoster sur ses plages le maquis
derrière crépitent du chant des cigales
mais c'est un autre sentier kenzo est
venu découvrir la balade sera sous
marine avec masque tuba balme et un
guide un port cros le parc naturel c'est
aussi sous l'eau la pêche est interdite
les bateaux n'ont pas le droit d'y jeter
l ancre alors les équilibres naturels se
reforme
c'est autour de ces différents
écosystèmes devenu rare que la randonnée
est organisée
l'objectif du parc c'est de mettre les
gens vraiment en contact avec des mines
sous-marines de qualité avec le plus
pédagogique c'est à dire qui leur permet
de comprendre comment ça fonctionne et à
partir de là on espère si vous voulez
que ce soit les adultes que ce soit les
enfants que chacun sera un peu
sensibiliser à l'intérêt de protection
parce qu'il aura découvert un milieu de
grande qualité
cette bouée permettent aux promeneurs de
se repérer chaque fois c'est une
spécificité du parcours qui est expliqué
les guides du parc national font aussi
découvrir aux randonneurs les secrets du
fonds de l'eau comme la présence dans
les frondaisons de possibles ni de cette
nacre dans dix mètres d'eau à peine
elle l'a peu près entre 25 et conforme
donc c'est énorme je pensais qu'on
parlait des anglais pendant longtemps on
les a fléchi pour en faire définir c'est
vrai ça dans les magasins maintenant on
nous appelle bon prix qu'elle a pu alors
va pas il plaquait submersible recense
les trente neuf espèces de poissons que
l'on peut croiser au cours de la
promenade la beauté de port cros touche
tout le monde même dominique serafini un
ancien de la calypso a été super et la
vita n'est que j'ai vu que j'étais gosse
on avait là je m'en fiche l'île de port
cros regorge de trésors pour les trouver
il suffit de savoir nager et de ne rien
toucher
pour que plus tard les enfants d'enzo et
les autres puissent découvrir eux aussi
ce sanctuaire épargné